joe biden who as you know is the acting
president of the united states this is a
man who uh gives speeches every now and
again and then accidentally when he goes
off teleprompter always says that he's
going to get in trouble when he starts
telling you the truth or he loses his
train of thought or fumbles and mumbles
or runs away from questions or they hide
him or all this stuff nonetheless the
guy is supposedly the president
now it is coming out that basically the
administration is coordinating with
mainstream media because they don't like
some of the coverage they're getting now
before i read you the quotes from the
daily wire really think about how crazy
this is we had four years of the orange
man being president where every single
story was about racism and xenophobia
and this is hitler and democracy is over
and everything there's basically in the
mainstream there's really no criticism
of biden you know like sure we're having
supply chain problems inflation is a
disaster in afghanistan like the list
goes on and on but there's really no
criticism real criticism of biden they
either blame it on trump or it's not you
know biden's doing the best he can he
released two days worth of gas you know
the guy's trying at least two days
around the gas that's fun uh anyway uh
the administration basically is
coordinating now with mainstream media
on how they should cover them uh we've
got some info here from the daily wire
cnn reported the white house not happy
with news media coverage news media's
coverage of the supply chain and economy
has been working behind the scenes
trying to reshape cover coverage in its
favor senior white house and
administration officials including nec
deputy directors david camen and bharat
rammuti along with
envoy john porsari have been briefing
major newsrooms over the past week a
source tells me the officials have been
discussing with newsroom trends
pertaining to job creation economic
growth supply chains and more the basic
argument that has been made that the
country's economy is in much better
shape than it was last year i'm told the
conversations have been productive with
anchors and reporters and producers
getting to talk with the officials
biden's approval rating is so low that
he has had a lower approval rating that
than every governor in the us and his
approval rating has dipped to as low as
18
in one state so first off on the biden
approval rating thing i mean this is the
man he got 81 million votes and don't
you doubt it
his approval rating is just absolutely
in the tank okay that doesn't matter
this idea though
that administration officials
go to newsrooms talk to news anchors
talk to reporters and journalists and
help them craft coverage does that sound
like journalism to you does that sound
like michael can you get me the
definition of the word journalism we're
going to get the definition the very
definition of the word does that sound
like journalism or does that sound like
scripting does that sound like uh
getting an approved narrative across
right if you're going into a room and
you're trying to get people to say the
things that you want them to say so
that's what they're doing they're
administration officials oh well the
economy is better than you think it is
and we're going to show you these things
that that sounds like what hollywood
would do not what journalism would do
i've got the very definition of the word
journalism journalism is the production
and distribution of reports on current
events based on facts and supported with
proof or evidence
well that sounds like journalism as we
knew it not journalism as we know it
anyway i suppose this doesn't surprise
any of you because obviously it didn't
surprise me but it was worth mentioning
because it's like the administration's
admitting it like we know all the stuff
they do behind the scenes right they
leak things to the new york times they
leak things to the washington post they
cover up things when it doesn't fit the
narrative but they're literally right in
front of our faces saying guys in
essence what they're saying is guys we
hand them the script we talk to the news
anchors wonder if they talk to chris
cuomo i wonder if they talk to don lemon
wonder if they talk to it talk to some
of these people you know it's like and
then you watch this stuff and you think
you're getting fact-based or proof or
evidence-based reporting from honest
people and what you're actually getting
is pravda you're actually just getting
talking points from the administration
you don't need talking points from an
administration to go down the street
like i can over here and basically still
see all of these boarded up stores or
virtually every single store almost
without exception saying fifteen dollars
an hour we're hiring people can't get
people to work because people are now on
the government dole these companies
these businesses these diners these
restaurants i assure you they're not
thriving and the idea
i'll try to give the devil is due
if
you believe the economies say a little
bit better than it was last year well
last year we were supposedly in the
worst pandemic of all time the pandemic
that the vaccines and old joe biden were
supposed to fix so is it possible at
some level at some analysis of the data
that the economy is a little bit better
now than when we were in sort of still
full lockdowns or half lockdowns or
whatever i suppose that might be true at
some level but you'd have to do a lot of
narrative work you'd have to do a lot of
fiction writing to make it really hold
water so anyway i don't believe these
people that's the bumper sticker